[Música]
llegó al poder de manera triunfal a
mediados del 2000 19 tras una aplastante
victoria boris johnson el líder de los
progres y en su momento le debo a
theresa may en el cargo del primer
ministro del reino unido- su aire
desparpajado lo mostraba tal vez como un
político atípico para downing street-
dada la coyuntura del reino unido- y su
deseo de retirarse de la unión europea
lo antes posible hacía pensar que su
cierto carácter de político rebelde era
lo que los británicos necesitaban ahora
que ese país dejaba el bloque europeo
una vez eso se concretó el reino unido-
encaró las dificultades de no tener el
respaldo de bruselas y es donde esa
rebeldía tenía que dejarse de lado y dar
paso al liderazgo fue este liderazgo
esperado por parte de boris johnson tres
años después johnson deja el cargo de
primer ministro totalmente desacreditado
criticado en medio de escándalos el
premier que se mostraba aferrado al
poder y se negaba a renunciar fue
empujado al abismo por su propia forma
política al partido de los conservadores
conocidos como los tories así se les
conoce en el interior del reino unido
veamos rápidamente algunos de los hechos
principales que han llevado a este
escándalo a esta crisis política en el
reino unido- boris johnson llegó al
cargo en 2019 como ya les decía y se va
de él tres años después renunció al
liderazgo de su partido pero ha dicho
que hasta que la formación política no
elija a un sucesor va a seguir en el
cargo de primer ministro las primeras
críticas en su contra llegaron alrededor
de abril de 2021 ante la gestión de la
pandemia del cob y 19 optó por la
inmunidad del rebaño pero el número de
contagiados y también de fallecidos que
crecía estrepitosamente llevó a que se
viera obligado a tener que tomar
decisiones ya un poco tarde incluso el
mismo paso por una unidad de cuidado
intensivo para ser tratado por el cob y
19 en diciembre del mismo año estalla el
partido cuando se dan a conocer algunas
informaciones algunos datos vídeos
fotografías sobre esas fiestas
realizadas en la sede de downing street
mientras el reino unido- estaba en
confinamiento
hecho es considerado como un punto de no
retorno como un parteaguas en su
gobierno y en su gestión para mayo del
2022 el descontento de los británicos se
vio ya en las urnas se vio reflejado en
las urnas su formación enfrentó una
importante caída en las elecciones
locales y también la popularidad de
johnson ya se veía seriamente afectada
esto llevó a que un mes después en junio
del 2022 tuviera que enfrentarse a un
voto de censura logró sobrevivir pero
era un voto de censura de los diputados
conservadores precisamente por el
escándalo del partido en este punto ya
el 40% de los diputados indicaron no
tener confianza en el primer ministro
para julio del 2022 comenzó otro
escándalo cuando integrantes de su
gabinete se vieron involucrados en un
escándalo sexual la falta de reacción y
las explicaciones tardías por parte de
johnson originaron una ola de renuncias
50 en total de integrantes de su
gabinete y también provocó una enorme
presión de su bancada conservadora que
llevó a la renuncia al liderazgo del
partido y por ende al cargo el primer
ministro que sigue entonces ahora para
johnson como es el reino unido- que deja
la era johnson dejar varios temas sobre
la agenda varios temas sobre la mesa muy
importantes como por ejemplo esa difícil
relación que tiene en londres y bruselas
porque el reino unido bajo el mandato de
boris johnson deseaba hacer cambios en
el protocolo de irlanda después del
presi que es esa frontera que hay entre
la república de irlanda que pertenece a
la unión europea y el territorio de
irlanda del norte que pertenece al reino
unido ya hemos hablado acá de la
controversia y toda la discusión que hay
en torno a este tema queda también en la
agenda el deseo independentista de
escocia el apoyo militar del reino unido
en la guerra de ucrania país en donde
boris johnson aunque ustedes no lo crean
es extremadamente popular porque este
país ha mostrado el respaldo al gobierno
del presidente evo lo de mercedes kit
desde el primer día que comenzó la
invasión rusa también que sigue entonces
para el reino unido- en su construcción
como país solitario sin el apoyo de la
unión europea que también enfrenta pues
muchos problemas económicos
entonces a analizar en el programa de
hoy en el debate de france 24 y para
conversar y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a paulina astros a ella
es directora del programa de estudios
europeos de la universidad de concepción
en chile
ella se conecta precisamente desde la
capital de la región del bío bío allí en
el sur de chile la ciudad de concepción
y desde la ciudad de londres según esta
conversación javier a ar se rifó ella de
cientista política ella también es
estudiante de doctorado en el institute
of the americas university college de
londres les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas y los
comentarios que deseen hacer en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24
bajo ese arroba santi lobo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 también les recuerdo
que nos pueden encontrar en youtube para
que vean nuestra señal en streaming y
también aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos escuchan en nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos del programa el
debate que están disponibles en papel
para paul podcast spotify deezer
y pueden seguir oyendo todo lo que
quieran de nuestro contenido pues muy
bien le doy la bienvenida entonces a
paulina en la ciudad de concepción para
comenzar este análisis y comenzar el
debate el punto de partida como llamo a
la primera pregunta es para conocer
opiniones de los invitados y paulina
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos y su opinión sobre la
salida de boris johnson plagado de
escándalos tres años después de haber
llegado digamos por la puerta grande
victorioso mostrándose muy seguro de sí
mismo ya era el momento para que boris
johnson dejara downing street como ésta
santiago gusta saludarte nuevamente el
momento boris johnson y la verdad es que
venían desde hace tiempo y en parte fue
la guerra de ucrania quien detuvo ese
momento recordemos que ante la guerra de
ucrania ya había un movimiento muy
fuerte al interior del partido
conservador
fundamentalmente aquellos que se le
llaman los rebeldes para juntar este
número de cartas
según las normas del partido conservador
permiten una censura interna eso ya
estaba en marcha el partido y todo lo
que tú has señalado se fue sumando y
justamente estos escándalos y estaba
casi listo eso cuando comienza la guerra
de ucrania y como también tú lo señalado
por y johnson aprovecha ese escenario
para mostrar liderazgo y para como
occidente dentro de la otan en apoyar a
ucrania esto hizo que los líderes
internamente detuvieran esta esta acción
sin embargo ahora ya lo que rebasó el
bajo tal como tú lo señalas te puede él
descubrir que uno de los diputados
aliados de boris johnson y que incluso
está a cargo de disciplina dentro el
partido también tiene acusaciones que él
reconoció de tocamientos y acoso
a otros hombres y boris johnson reconoce
que sabía de esas situaciones y de otras
y fue muy de él y eso en definitiva
es el detonante de lo que ocurre el día
de ayer partiendo con la renuncia de dos
grandes que son suministro de la salud y
el ministro de finanzas y lo que lleva
finalmente a estas 55 renuncias en total
de altos cargos y que lo obligan a
dimitir como jefe del partido
conservador es un poco en resumen
paulina lo que yo decía en la
introducción es hacer ese balance entre
rebeldía política y la necesidad de
liderazgo en donde creo que se pone eso
en la balanza y es la factura que le
cobran a boris johnson en esta instancia
en donde había que tomar decisiones paso
ahora hasta la ciudad de londres allí
presentaba a nuestra invitada javier
arze riffo javiera bienvenida al
programa y su opinión sobre la salida
del primer ministro boris johnson que va
a permanecer en el cargo hasta tanto su
formación política decida quién es el
nuevo líder de ese partido adelante
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
saludar a paulina
e
por lo menos lo que se alcanzó a probar
acá es que
hay una relación moral con el tema del
comportamiento de
posición son y que finalmente claro como
como bien decían ustedes al principio y
paulina coordina lo destacaba tiene que
ver con estas acusaciones de mis
conducta parte d
chief wii
pero acá hay antecedentes anteriores y
hay otras cuestiones más que también se
requieren agregar la situación de reino
unido en estos momentos nosotros podemos
observar que está bastante deteriorada
económicamente con respecto al prsc y de
hecho se han ido prácticamente todos los
migrantes
de inglaterra sobre todo los migrantes
europeos y eso ha traído como
consecuencia también que uno un gran
porcentaje de universidades dejen de
percibir ingresos
y por ende el sector de educación serio
dependiendo pero también hemos tenido
problemas y esto lo estamos viviendo que
quienes habitamos el país
problemas con el precio de los alimentos
ya que a la inflación internacional hay
que agregar el problema del mismo
prestige y la situación económica de los
británicos se ha ido deteriorando
entonces eso también como consecuencia
no solamente del coi tiene porque
también de la guerra y a eso también hay
que sumarle el préstamo entonces
evidentemente hay un problema porque
además dentro del mismo partido
conservador tampoco era una cuestión tan
unificada en términos de posición
política con desde todo el partido de
salirse de la unión europea y por lo
tanto
esto vendría también como a revestir aún
más
la posición de lo que ocurre y por otro
lado lo que lo que también a propósito
de esta cosa es moral el tema del
partido yo creo que es lo que va a calar
fundamentalmente enzo en la sociedad
inglesa por la sociedad inglesa en una
sociedad muy de palabra muy de respetar
las normas y prácticamente lo que no se
le perdona johnson es que la propia
reina en esta política de austeridad
haya tenido que velar prácticamente sola
a su marido leer mientras quien da un
script esta gente estaba haciendo
fiestas sin ningún tipo de medidas de
seguridad y por lo tanto es ese tipo de
situaciones también podría instalar
bastante hondo que usted también de
relatar las las elecciones tuvo locales
al partido conservador no le sigue bien
y en estas elecciones está file acción
que hubo ahora el 23 de junio tampoco le
fue entonces el mantener a ahora johnson
a la cabeza del partido pero presentaba
un riesgo sobre todo de pérdida de
capitalización en las próximas
elecciones que que viene en el próximo
año y allí sí que el partido conservador
podría tener una merma tan grande en su
votación y perder la mayoría en el
parlament
paulina como es el reino unido que deja
boris johnson de aquí tenemos un
panorama un poco
los diferentes escenarios a nivel
político de a nivel económico pero cómo
es este país que él recibe que lleva a
través de esa transición del president
es un momento histórico para la unión
europea y para este país en sí y que es
lo que él deja tres años después
mira yo creo que deja un país y un
mandato bastante caótico donde
indudablemente las consecuencias del
break si se han notado a todo nivel que
fueron incrementadas evidentemente
también por la pandemia pero además con
un mal manejo en
las relaciones con la unión europea
porque también como tú lo señalaba al
inicio
boris johnson es finalmente el que lleva
a cabo
y logra que el parlamento británico
apruebe lo que es el acuerdo de salida
con el reino unido- cosa que no había
podido hacer theresa may y lo logra
hacer con una cláusula quiera
justamente lo de las dos irlandas
este famoso protocolo de irlanda y que
él ahora ha decidido romper y logró
pasar una ley justamente que va en
contra y violando el derecho
internacional y esto hace que sus
relaciones y en las relaciones actuales
del reino unido con la unión europea se
estén viendo mucho mucho más tensas de
lo que partieron cuando él asume en
segundo lugar está dejando también un
reino unido con una fractura que hoy día
se nota mucho más que con escocia
la ministra principal nicola exterior me
acaba de mencionar o se acaba de
informar que van a insistir con un
referéndum el año 2023
boris johnson termina su mandato o
digamos oficialmente antes de la
renuncia porque todavía sigue en
ejercicio señalando que no va a admitir
que el parlamento británico
autorice este referéndum lo que pone al
reino unido a inglaterra en particular
con escocia en una situación muy tensa
situación tensa también que se produce
con irlanda del norte donde también sinn
fein gana las elecciones y eso le
provoca un problema en las tensiones
políticas y por otro lado gales también
que forma parte del reino unido donde
están sufriendo todas estas
consecuencias negativas está dejando un
partido conservador con una falta de
liderazgo clara porque no se sabe bien
quién va a asumir como reemplazante con
un partido laborista que está subiendo
en las encuestas que si las elecciones
fueran hoy día ganaría donde han perdido
en en algunos distritos y en las
regionales particularmente perdieron
mucho espacio y fundamentalmente lo que
se llama el muro rojo que es el área
norte donde el partido laborista perdió
muchos y muchos parlamentarios en la
elección de 2019 bueno se han ido
recobrando algunos espacios ahí y lo que
el partido conservador tiene y el reino
unido- hoy día es un desafío tremendo
ante un contexto internacional de
incertidumbre y inflación de guerra y
evidentemente con estos problemas
políticos internos como es el sentir de
los británicos han pasado pocas horas
desde la renuncia al liderazgo de los
conservadores por parte de boris johnson
pero cuál es el sentir del británico de
a pie de la situación que se está
viviendo de como el país ha transición
ado a través de esta salida de la unión
europea y ha logrado
salirse
de este bloque y está construyendo
digamos un país independiente sin la
ayuda de bruselas que le está costando
mucho y el sentir en cuanto a el mandato
y el liderazgo que tuvo boris johnson a
lo largo de estos tres años
si hoy día estaba mirando la bbc- porque
le hacían entrevistas a las personas y
en general yo diría qué bonito son no
era tan tan odiado como como podríamos
pensar
los latinoamericanos que si nosotros
analizamos la política británica en
clave latinoamericana creo que nos
podemos meter en un problema yo creo que
en parte
no no estaría tan cierta de decir que el
partido laborista está en condiciones de
capitalizar esto
porque también boris johnson a pesar de
esta figura que podría aparecer mea
grotesca se parece bastante como al
británico promedio y hasta le hacía
gracia hasta de esto como candidato era
era bastante gracioso está este
personaje que además no tenía miedo como
al ridículo le gustan las fiestas las
mujeres esta cosa como que al parecer
era como una especie como de alter ego y
les gustaba mucho a los británicos y
tampoco
si nosotros pensamos que esto podría
ocurrir en una crisis política no sé
tanto como lo hemos tenido en chile como
en perú etcétera o en otros países
colombia mismo en que la gente ocupa los
espacios públicos y está feliz la verdad
es que hoy día no se vio mucho más que
algunas personas más fuera de edad o en
espíritu pero no hay protestas no hay
nada yo creo que acá hay una cultura
además democrática muy de traspasar los
cargos rápidamente de tratar de resolver
los problemas dentro de los partidos
y lo que sí es como como gran lección yo
creo que el tema de expert pasteur post
que es precisamente el sistema electoral
que tienen los británicos ya no no no
constriñe tanto la representatividad en
dos partidos y en las elecciones
anteriores tanto los laboristas como los
liberaldemócratas fueron los que más
subieron a propósito de unas alianzas
medias para citas que hacen allí los
liberaldemócratas tratan de ocupar en
parte del centro y en ese sentido y con
esto termino yo creo que él lo curioso
va a ser quien va a seguir o quién va a
suceder a johnson porque de las tres
personas que están ahora encabezando las
listas estamos hablando de tres
migrantes o sea de tres personas nacidas
en gran reino unido pero vamos a hablar
de quienes pueden llegar a ese cargo
tengo ese tema también en la agenda para
comentarlo lo vamos a hablar más
adelante quiero preguntarle a paulina
aquí por estas formaciones políticas
también a javier a para que entre las
dos
hagamos un panorama de cómo entonces
están los partidos ustedes mencionaban
que los laboristas han logrado ganar un
poco más de popularidad las encuestas
así lo evidencian si las elecciones
fueran en estos días prácticamente
ganarían tienen una aprobación un poco
más favorable y claramente estos
escándalos y hemos llegado al escenario
en el que estamos porque la imagen de
los conservadores pues se ve un poco
afectada entonces cómo ven ustedes el
escenario político cómo están las
fuerzas políticas paulina cómo pueden
capitalizar los laboristas este esta
coyuntura y qué pueden hacer los tories
para poder mejorar la imagen y recuperar
ese liderazgo que han tenido
lo primero que deben hacer los
conservadores es evidentemente elegir la
persona que va a suceder a boris johnson
y que trate de aunar la mayor cantidad
de grupos políticos al interior de los
propios conservadores los conservadores
una de las graves crisis que han tenido
y de hecho cuando david cameron en enero
del 2003 se anuncia este referéndum
del prep si es por razones de política
interna porque dentro el partido
conservador hay una a la que es mucho
más euroescéptica
incluso algunos eurófobos que que se
salieron del partido y se fueron al you
keep o el partido el break sito hoy día
y otro que son mucho más moderados y
también que querían incluso quedarse
entre la unión europea entonces hay
varias almas dentro del propio partido
conservador que tienen que aclarar ahora
y elegir a un buen liderazgo que no no
aparece claramente hoy día van a tener
que hacerlo con esta sucesión de
elecciones por lo tanto tienen un
desafío muy grande y además de gobernar
porque tienen que gobernar ahora aparte
de esta con esta crisis de credibilidad
que tiene el gobierno tienen que liderar
con este escenario tan negativo como el
que estábamos señalando desde el punto
de vista económico social y sus
relaciones con la unión europea por otro
lado está los laboristas quienes desde
que tienen y corbin deja el partido
steiner lo que ha hecho justamente
avanzar pero no lo ha logrado como
algunos pretendían con la fuerza que
algunos creían y más ha sido el avance
de los laboristas por errores no
forzados del partido conservador que por
una iniciativa o una acción de los
laboristas pero dentro de eso pueden
ganar los liberales demócratas también
han ido aumentando pese que no han
logrado a tener un peso como no tuvieron
el siglo pasado ni tampoco han llegado
al punto de que de formar gobierno con
otra coalición común hicieron con david
cameron pero eso yo no lo descartaría
una coalición entre laboristas y
liberaldemócratas si es que lo lidera el
ciclo laborista no lograrán tener la
mayoría los verdes han ido ganando un
poquitito espacio pero todavía siguen
siendo partidos menores con él un grado
de representación y evidentemente aquí
hay un número importante de escaños que
corresponden al partido nacionalista
escocés claro quien tiene ahí también un
peso relevante más aún con con el tema
de el referéndum y de la independencia
claro javier a su opinión sobre el
panorama político como estos partidos
pueden capitalizar esta coyuntura y
cautivar votos
si yo coincido completamente con paulina
porque de la forma
dentro de las dos alas entre el corby
mismo y el los señores de blair se
instala como entremedio la facción del
actual líder que se llama active stay
mer y él también está con un poco a la
espera de lo que de lo que hagan los
laboristas en ese sentido y todavía está
perdón los conservadores y que es lo que
van a proponer y ippon y se puede estar
levantando también la figura del alcalde
de londres que se él también ha tenido
una figuración bastante importante
además yo muy buen alcalde pero creo que
acá lo importante y lo que viene es cuál
va a ser el cambio de la política
finalmente de los conservadores con la
caída de boris johnson él está tratando
de quedarse en el poder ahora hasta
quería hacerlo hasta hasta el otoño
situación que allá aún a un montón
incluso líderes del partido han
observado les parecía un exceso y por lo
tanto mañana van a ver cuando llaman a
esto es lo que se llama como el desafío
del liderazgo dentro del partido para
poder buscar una sucesión
los cuales están compitiendo tres ex
ministros de hacienda de
los conservadores que han sido muy muy
poderosos estás una que es de acción de
encendido india está
javi y perdón es allí que es pakistán es
aquí además era suministra salud y es de
pakistán y para wii que también
tiene un origen iraquí entonces estamos
viendo que probablemente el tema de la
migración también vaya a tomar un camino
bastante interesante que son estos tres
liderazgos más más
representativos y los que podrían
competir en mayores y mejores
condiciones en esta en esta en esta
disputa por el por ser el primer
ministro y estar de mejor forma para las
elecciones ahora creo que es súper
importante ver cuál va a ser el rol
ideológico acá de lo de estos estos
partidos ya sé dónde van a estar por qué
una cosa va a ser mejorar o restablecer
las relaciones con la unión europea para
que se pueda subsanar un poco la
situación económica tan terrible que
está teniendo las consecuencias bastante
como inesperadas se podría decir de
haberse salido solo también hay otras
cuestiones que están en disputa que
tienen que ver con el y el servicio
nacional de salud cuyo objetivo siempre
ha sido en los conservadores
destruirlo o desmantelar lo entonces es
bien importante porque él es y es muy
importante para la sociedad británica
paulina javiera ya mencionaba algunos de
los nombres que se empiezan a perfilar
al interior de los conservadores para
llegar a este cargo todavía no hay un
calendario presentado por el comité 1922
que es este grupo de los conservadores
que se encarga de la toma de decisiones
del partido y es el encargado de
convocar pues a esta elección del futuro
líder de la formación que se puede decir
de estos tres posibles perfiles de
candidatos que hay sobre la mesa que
como javiera dice muestran un poco una
realidad británica que hasta ahora no se
ha
a través de sus gobernantes y es esa
sociedad cosmopolita del reino unido-
que involucra personas procedentes de
todos los territorios de ultramar y
también de territorios que en algún
momento fueron colonia británica o que
pertenecen a la mancomunidad
ahora que hay dos temas uno es que yo
veo y día de mañana cuáles eran cuáles
son los que dentro del partido
conservador que ya hay como 15
candidaturas ya de las cuales se está
hablando la primera de ellas que es el
ex es el ex ministro de defensa no no es
no son los ministros de finanzas que si
bien han sido nombrados
tienen algunos problemas sobre todo el
caso de 31 que tiene si bien ha tenido
un cierto liderazgo tiene problemas
primero por un escándalo con las cuentas
fiscales de su señora y en segundo lugar
porque él fue multado también
por el partido y eso hizo que su
credibilidad cayera sin embargo al
ministro defensa que hoy día está
apareciendo con con bastante más fuerza
como como pudiera ser este posible
sucesor y fundamentalmente por la el
fuerte apoyo que le ha dado el reino
unido a lo bueno de unir selenski y a
ucrania y el rol y la digamos dentro de
la otan que ha mostrado con bastante
fuerza
el propio work johnson por otro lado
también ojo al nombre de listas que
en la ministra de relaciones exteriores
que hoy día se encontraba en indonesia y
volvió al estaba volviendo al reino
unido justamente no es un hombre ya
estaba sonando antes el nombre de ella
venía ya cuando seguía presentar la
moción de censura antes de la guerra de
ucrania y ese nombre siempre estaba ahí
en ojo también ese nombre aparte de lo
que ya se ha mencionado javier a que es
el ex ministro de salud que uno de los
que suena fuerte que se enfrentó además
a dominique cummings que recordemos que
dominica min zhu fue el principal asesor
de boris johnson al inicio y fue la
mente detrás del preside y bueno se
enfrentó el en algún momento y fue el
primero que renunció de hecho ayer y él
ha sido uno de los más críticos con
boris johnson entonces hay un abanico de
posibilidades no sabemos hacia dónde los
finalmente el partido conservador
a poner fichas
esto lo determina el comité 1922 como
tus señaladas tienen que establecer el
calendario son votaciones sucesivas
donde se va eliminando al que tiene
menor votación hasta que queden
finalmente los dos primeros las dos
primeras mayorías y esos son los que se
llevan a votación para toda la
militancia el partido conservador y
determinan quién va a ser el próximo a
la próxima primera ministra si el líder
del partido y automáticamente primer
ministro o primera ministra del reino
unido- así es como funciona y esto puede
durar semanas
dependiendo también la cantidad de
candidatos y candidatas que se presenten
y eso por lo tanto es indeterminado y
eso es un procedimiento muy particular
algo a lo que no estamos habituados en
américa latina donde tenemos régimen
presidencialista esto es parte de la
política británica así ha sido a lo
largo de los de los años y así es como
se elige el primer ministro en este país
punto importante paulina para analizar
también desde la perspectiva de bruselas
de la unión europea este cambio de
gobierno qué
vecina entonces en el reino unido una
vez llegue el sucesor de boris johnson
le puede dar un respiro a bruselas en
esta difícil relación que se desencadenó
entre las dos partes a raíz del presi
sin duda porque por johnson representaba
aquí el sector no solamente más
partidaria el beshir sino que además que
como yo ya lo señale quería violar el
acuerdo de que tienen con el reino unido
con este protocolo respecto de las
irlandas y además que fue un protocolo y
con una norma que él mismo fue el que
estableció porque es una de las cosas
que se renegociaron en relación a la
propuesta que había había acordado
teresa men
sin duda que dado los efectos negativos
que ha tenido el presi para la economía
y para la propia sociedad y el reino
unido- que ahora de verdad están
sabiendo lo que es el preside porque el
break sheet recién comenzó no es que
haya comenzado con el referéndum sino
que ahora están realmente conociendo los
efectos
bruselas yo creo que indudablemente
sonrieron hoy día claro al saber que va
a haber un cambio de gobierno esperando
que aquel que se arribe finalmente
decida no continuar con esta ley que es
una ley interna que viola el tratado con
la unión europea y que mejoren las
relaciones porque en final son
finalmente quienes se ven perjudicados
son ambas partes pero quien más pierde
es el reino unido- 30 bien 27 países
como son los integrantes de la unión hoy
día si javier también importante de la
coyuntura europea es ese apoyo que
mencionaba yo que le ha dado el reino
unido- militarmente a través de la otan
y también pues por iniciativa del país
el gobierno de volodymyr selenski en
ucrania es impresionante la popularidad
de boris johnson en el interior de
ucrania
solamente superado por el presidente es
el en esquí y mucho más arriba en
porcentaje si se le compara con otros
líderes europeos como emanuel maco olaf
scholz el canciller alemán y otras
figuras de la política de la unión
europea en esta relación entre kiev y
londres puede verse
trastocada con este cambio de gobierno o
por estar ahí al interior de la otan
esto simplemente va a mantenerse tal
cual como ha venido desarrollándose no
en general a la política particularmente
de asuntos de exteriores y sobre todo
temas de defensas son políticas de
estado así yo creo que no no no podría o
no no abruptamente no decidían cómo
sacar precisamente trabajo o dejar de
apoyar esto además en las
manifestaciones que más nosotros podemos
observar seguidas tanto en la misma
población acá en trafalgar square y en
varias partes más es precisamente a
favor de ucrania o sea yo hay una
conciencia de eso también y siempre y
ponerlas las banderas están en los
edificios públicos así que yo creo que
no habría ningún
como cambio mayor respecto de por qué
justamente somos lo que permite además
me parece en eso yo yo no no no soy tan
conoce ahora como como paulina de esta
de estos equilibrios de poderes
más más bien europeos pero me parece que
les permite estar en el contexto a pesar
de haber seguido de de la unión europea
javier ahí podría ser también el inicio
de un acercamiento con un rusia tal vez
puede ser un nuevo inicio en las
relaciones con ese país
hay que decirle ese tema pero si acá
llama curiosamente la atención la
relación tan cercana que tienen con
algunos personeros rusos que vienen muy
fuertemente acá la migración sobre todo
de personas con mucho dinero rusia es
muy palpable y sobre todo también la
relación cercana que hay de algunos
personeros del partido conservador con
ellos
yo no me atrevería a decir que vaya a
ser una relación tan declarada pero eso
ya está ya ya existe hace ya harto
tiempo de esto hay una especie
especulación que los precios por ejemplo
de la burbuja inmobiliaria de londres
tiene mucho que ver con la venida de
estos textos rusos de mayores ingresos
entonces hay una relación ahí
establecida hace mucho rato si una
relación siempre había una relación
histórica muy cercana entre londres y
moscú
me quedan ya un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa llegó a las
conclusiones le preguntó entonces a
paulina que va a seguir entonces en este
juego político en el reino unido- que
sigue para este país
copio un poco una pregunta que hace la
bbc en alguno de sus artículos y es que
no podrían descartar de pronto un
regreso de boris johnson a la escena
política ya los altos cargos allá en el
reino unido- cómo lo ve usted paulina
a ver en primer lugar boris johnson
acaba de informar según reductores que
él va a continuar como diputado como
parlamentario una vez deje de ser el
primer ministro o sea no tiene intención
de renunciar a su escaño lo que ya nos
indica que él va a continuar en la vida
política y sería hasta que termine su
mandato si es que no hay elecciones
anticipadas sería hasta el 2024 que
serían las próximas elecciones generales
que lo que se viene se viene bastante
incertidumbre se vienen los efectos
negativos de toda esta de lo que
significaba no solamente lo que ya hemos
conversado del escenario internacional e
interno sino también de la de la crisis
de gobernabilidad que está teniendo el
partido conservador
boris johnson yo no lo doy por muerto
políticamente creo que en políticas no
hay muertos y así hemos visto varios que
han vuelto incluso después de haber
ejercido el poder y haber ser retirado y
haber estado acá si se les daba por
fuera
el juego y sin embargo volvieron como el
mismo jeremy corbyn en su momento lado
pero
le va a ser difícil porque el interior
del partido conservador hay un sector
que le critica mucho a boris johnson las
medidas adoptadas durante este mandato
aunque se acercaron mucho a la izquierda
plato como que había abandonado el alma
del partido conservador tradicional y
puro entonces ahí yo creo que hay un
tema que un observador sería un poco
difícil esa vuelta pero estos segundos
para su conclusión rápidamente por favor
que sigue para el reino unido
yo diría que vienen tiempos de bastante
turbulencia
bien en tiempos también en los que se va
a tener que forzar a los partidos a
poner los temas en la agenda nosotros
estamos teniendo esta crisis
inflacionaria muy brutal servicios
básicos están subiendo un 40 por ciento
estoy hablando la luz del agua
etcétera
pero si solo quiero quedarme con una
frase que me acordé a propósito que se
dice siempre en mi país que nadie muere
en política y yo creo que la política
cíclica y que boris johnson es bastante
resiliente y tiene altas capacidades de
poder reencarnarse en un futuro no tan
lejano en las próximas coyunturas pues a
javiera ya paulina les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros haber hecho
este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 en américa latina' ustedes
puede seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales y por supuesto los
invito para que escuchen el contenido
del programa también en nuestro podcast
sigan con france24
[Música]